DANIEL FRIEDMAN: Hello and welcome. This is model stream
number 007.2. It's the 18 January
2023. We're back in our second session
on pymdp. Welcome back,
Conor. Thanks for joining again. And off
to you for a presentation that you will
weave together with some some code
examples. And the notebook that we'll
use is in the video description. So
thanks again, Conor. Off to you.
CONOR HEINS: Great. Thank you, Daniel. It's great to be back
here again. I think I've been here maybe
four or five times now. So it's always a
pleasure to be with you all. So, yeah,
as Daniel said, this is the second model
stream in a two part series where we'll
be discussing implementing active
inference with PMDP. There is
some background that I'm assuming you
either know from your own research into
active inference and palm DPS in
particular, or because you've watched
the first part of the series. So I'll
just say that to start with. Like, if
you want background, I would encourage
you to go watch the first part where we
talk about PMDP, the motivation for the
package, what you can do with it in kind
of sweeping terms. And then today we're
actually going to go in and use it to
code up an active inference agent
performing a task, like a reinforcement
learning style task that's very
similar to classic active inference
tasks that you can find in the
literature. Yeah. So as Daniel said,
I'm going to step through the slides. I
have pauses for questions and stuff,
but we also have pauses for code live
coding or side by side coding. So I'll
take a pause from the slides and I'll go
over to the Collab notebook.
The link is in the description of the
YouTube video, and we'll kind of code
up this agent based on things that we
discuss in the slides. It's not that
I'll be actually writing code. I'll just
be running cell blocks.
If anyone who's viewing wants to
do it themselves, you can open the Co
Lab notebook. Actually, let's start by
doing that.
So this should be the Collab notebook
that you get brought to when you click
on the link. And this is one caveat.
You need to have a Google account to use
this because co op is linked to your
Google drive of your Google account. So
if you're doing this on your own,
this is a shared link. But it's not you
can't edit it. You can't write to it.
So what you have to do is go to file up
here and then save a copy and drive.
And then you'll get your own personal,
private copy of the notebook. And I'll
do that right now because I'll create a
run copy where we can manipulate it all
together in real time. So I'll just call
it run. Copy.
And I'll start by just installing
Hinton, this colab environment. Pi MDP.
So Colab is kind of like Jupiter's
notebooks. It's an interactive cloud
hosted notebook for running different
kinds of code, but mainly Python code.
So while that's installing, and I'll run
that as well, we can start with the
slides. Okay,
so I'll just start with a quick review
from last time, and again, go back to
the video if you want to see the full
picture of what we discussed. So the
generative models, the kind of brains of
the agents that will be constructing are
these partially observed Markov decision
processes or palm DPS. They have various
parameters, and it's kind of up to you
how to parameterize them. But under
active inference, we typically have
these four main components. There's
fifth and 6th, depending on how
complicated of a model you want to
create. But these components kind of
represents the agent's beliefs about the
world that it's operating in. So these
are usually hand designed or at least
generally structured on a case by case
basis, encoding to the behavioral task
that you're trying to model. So we have
the A matrix or A array, which encodes
the agent's beliefs about how hidden
states of the world that it's doing
coherence about relate to the
observations that it gets. You have the
B array, which encoding beliefs
about transitions or beliefs about
dynamics. So how do hidden states relate
to each other over time? You have the C
vector or C array, which encodes agents
prior preferences for seeing certain
sorts of sensations. So this kind of
plays the role of a quasi reward
function, and it has the effect of
biasing agents action selection such
that it's more likely to visit states of
affairs that a priority, expects to see
I e. Goal directed behavior. It wants to
achieve some goal. And then we have the
D vector, which is kind of a baseline
prior about what is the state of the
world before I get any observations,
like what do I believe the hidden state
distribution is? And again, I'm glossing
over this because I assume that you know
about things like categorical
distinctions.
All the details of these different
arrays are explained more in the first
video. And just again, to show
the graphical model, we have the A array
relating hidden states in red to
observations in Bleu. We have the B
matrix or B array that relate hidden
states to themselves over time. So how
does the world chance? And then we have
policies Pi, which are sequences or
collections of actions that affect
transitions and thereby change the state
of the world. And then you have this
critical quasi pseudovalue function to
active inference in palmdp's. Active
inference in general, which is the
expected free energy. And the expected
free energy is the thing you try to
minimize as you optimize your beliefs
about policies. So the best policies are
those that minimize expected free energy
and that has a bunch of interesting
terms that lend active inference all of
its interesting, curious, information
seeking behavior. And then this prior
over observations factors into the
computation of that expected free
energy. So if you have a particular
prior preference to see some
observations that will affect which
policies get more or less expected free
energy, and then you use that to
actually choose a policy. And then of
course, we have the D vector, which
parameterizes the initial beliefs about
his and states. So today we're
going to actually dive in and write out
our own ABCs and DS for particular
generative model. We don't have to worry
about writing out our own functions that
do inference or do planning. All of that
will be handled by the abstractions
provided by prime VP, particularly in
the agent class. So the agent class
takes the components of the generative
model. It gives you this very kind of
black box API that you can just use to
perform active inference.
In the last video, we talked about
different levels of abstraction. This is
like the top level of abstraction in Pi
MDP, where you're just passing a
generative model to an agent and then
kind of pressing go on the agent having
to interact with the task environment.
So typically this is another class,
like an environment class or a task
class. And then you just kind of string
the two together in an action perception
loop and you get a simulation
of behavior under active inference.
And this is a standard thing you'll see
in like OpenAI gym or other
reinforcement learning packages. You'll
have usually like an environment class
and an agent class, and they exchange
actions and observations in a loop. So
we designed the API of Pymdp, very much
inspired by that.
Okay, so before we start writing down
the generative model so that A-B-C and
D, I want to spend a little bit of time
exploring the idea of factorized state
spaces. And this is important because
not only the model we're working today,
it's important to understand
factorization in both observations and
hidden states, but for almost
all the most interesting palmdp models
you're going to want to build, it's
going to be really crucial to factorize
your system in some way. Not only
because it becomes easier to reason
about and work with when things are
factorized, but also it handles a lot of
computational explosions that happen if
you don't factorize your state space.
So it's often useful to categorically
separate observations into different
modalities and hidden states into
different factors. So what this means is
that when we get an observation, we're
actually getting a collection of
different observations, one coming from
each distinct sensory modality or
channel. So similarly for hidden states,
at any given time, the hidden states are
described by a distinct set of different
features, or what we call hidden state
factors. And so we refer to this as a
factorized representation because the
different modalities are independent of
each other, and the different hidden
states are also independent of each
other. Their dynamics are so they evolve
in time without affecting the other
hidden state factors. So that's formally
written down as follows. Like the
modalities are conditionally
independent of each other. Given the
hidden states, that's what this
factorization of the likelihood looks
like. So you can think of
the different modalities as different
sensory channels like vision, audition,
somata sensation, and they provide their
own distinct type of information which
are then integrated together during
coherence. And factorizing the hidden
states is like the idea that any given
time the world can be described by
independent features, like an object
being described by both its location and
space, as well as its identity and
factorizing. The state's representations
of the model in this way allows for a
few different distinct advantages. One
is computational efficiency, both in
terms of memory and CPU.
It simplifies the structure of
generative model itself, so it lends it
a bit of interpretability and
transparency. So there's only certain
sets of variables that represent the
agent's beliefs about one feature of the
environment, for instance. And then
finally, some would argue it has a
degree of neuronal or biological
plausibility. And it's consistent with
the idea of factorized what others would
call modular representations in the
brain. So this group of neuronal
populations deals with representing
where something is in space, and this
group of neuronal populations deals with
representing the identity or what the
thing is. So that's kind of the reason
we do this factorization.
So one of the most classic examples of
the early examples we do in Pinevp, and
this can be found on the documentation
and on the main page is this grid world
example where the agent is kind of
navigating in a 2D grid world space. In
the notebooks online, we do like three
by three grid world. So there's nine
total locations. And in a fully
unfactorized or what we call an
enumerated state space representation,
every location in grid world has its own
particular identity or state. So we just
arbitrary can label them like location
zero all the way to location eight. And
that covers all nine levels of
gridworld. This is fine, but especially
for a small state space like a three by
three grid world. But it kind of taxes
our memory and our interpretability
a little bit because we have to remember
exactly how our nine indices map to the
different places in grid world. So if
I'm in the middle of the grid, I need to
have some kind of look up table to say,
okay, location four is like
zero or one comma one I e, the middle
location in the grid. In a factorized
representation, the grid could be
represented as two orthogonal or
independent hidden state factors. One is
something like the x displacement or the
horizontal displacement, which now just
takes three values like which column of
grid world are you in? And then vertical
displacement or y position, which is
something like which row of grid world
M-I-N. And so now each hidden state is
not a single nine dimensional vector,
but it's actually a combination or a
pair of two hidden states factors. So
two, three vectors instead of a single
nine vector. And then a given hidden
states itself is picked out by a
coincidence of these two hidden states
factors. So if the x position is one and
the y position is two, then it means I'm
in one
comma two. So like the middle bottom up
the grid world. And then once
you do this, so once we have a
factorized hidden state representation,
it has implication for the way we
construct the generative model. So in a
kind of simple generative model, you
would just have one B array that in the
original grid world example just is like
nine possible hidden states, the nine
possible locations of where I just was
that maps to the nine possible
subsequent hidden states. So the nine
possible locations I could be going to.
And then you'd have that nine by nine
matrix conditioned on the different
actions. So in the grid world demo,
the actions are typically local like
move up, move left, move down, move
right. But once you factorize things,
you're going to actually now have a
collection of B matrices. And this is a
consequence of the factorization across
the transition models that we discussed
a few slides ago. So you're going to
have one B matrix or one set of B arrays
for the X displacement. So how does the
agent move in the X direction? These are
what each of these X displacement
B matrices look like, cognition on
different actions. So this is what it
looks like for moving left, this is what
the B matrix looks like for moving
right. And this is what it looks like
for stay. And then similarly you have
another B matrix that encodes the
agent's abilities to move in the
vertical direction or y displacement.
And similarly they actually look
identical because the world is
like rotation and translation and
variant and you'll have another
smaller B array just for y movement.
This is a very simple example. We're not
going to actually do this in code
because it's kind of trivial, but it's
just an example of how instead of having
a location fully enumerated
representation, you can split that up
into basically a y axis and an X axis.
So now we're not going to simulate an
active inference agent, but we're just
going to play around with these data
structures to get you used to the idea
of factorized representations and how
that manifests in the code. So now we'll
go over to Colab. So if you've been
running this on your own, disk should
all be downloaded.
So you've installed interactively PMDP,
that's the whole name of the package
that's now in your environment. And then
you should also run this some basic
imports like NumPy and pimedp, which is
now in the environment. Okay? And so the
basic variables that you'll see are
things like there's a few variables
that are almost always part of any time
DP workflow. And this is very much
mirrored on how it's done in SPM in the
Dem tool box. So typically you'll have a
list that specifies the dimensionalities
or the number of different levels of
each hidden state factor. So for our
three by three grid world nine possible
states, we have one x factor of three
levels and one y factor of three levels.
And then the length of that list tells
us the total number of hidden state
factors. So in this case, we have two
hidden state factors. And then similarly
you have hidden states are factorized,
and then similarly you factorize your
control states. So for every hidden
state factor, there's also going to be a
control state factor. And the fact that
these are also three dimension each just
basically means that the agent has three
possible action in the x axis and three
possible actions in the y axis. And then
the number of control factors is also
going to be two in that case. And so we
have some nice utility functions that
can quickly build a brain given the
two things that are necessary, the numb
states and NUM controls variables. So
you just do initialize empty B
NUM states and NUM controls, and then
you'll have a B matrix that
has the correct shapes and stuff.
So three rows, three columns, and three
possible actions for the x direction and
similarly for the y direction. So this
is just basic setting up your variables.
And often we'll have these solution
cells that are hidden underneath each
little quasiexercise, so that's
something you can do as well.
Okay? And so that's just initializing
and empty array, right? So we don't
actually know what those contingencies
are that we saw in the slides, but if we
want to populate this thing, so this is
what each factor specific V array looks
like, then we have to go into these
matrices and actually fill out the rows,
columns and third order slices with
numbers. So for instance, this loop
where we loop over factors and we fill
out the different entries of the B
array. What this will do is just encode
those local actions like move left,
move right for the x factor, and then
move up, move down for the y factor.
And so once you've run that code,
you've basically filled out all the
numbers in that big empty B array that
you started. And then you can use things
like the plot likelihood function to
plot these likelihood distributions,
action conditioned likelihood
distributions as matrices. So this is
move left. For instance, if we're in the
x hidden state factor, and if we change
this to a one, we've changed the action
index, then this is move right,
and then similarly if we change this,
this is move down
if we're doing action one here.
So darker colors, whether it's grayscale
or red, or whatever, almost unanimously
in prime DP, the darker colors represent
more probability.
So instead of having to display numbers,
we'll just show darker numbers. Okay,
so now let's go back to the slides and
talk about the A arrays. So in our
unfactorized, fully enumerated grid
world example, and again, I'll refer you
to the documentation of prime VP if you
want to play around with that example.
The hidden state factors, which are just
these nine kind of Arbitrarily labeled
locations map to an observation
modality, which is like the agent's
sensation of its own position, kind of
appropriate GPS modality. You could
think of it as like they're sensing
where they are at any given time. And so
there are various ways you could encode
that. But let's just pretend that they
have a very high fidelity GPS,
so they're getting precise GPS readouts
of where they are at any given time. So
in a fully enumerated world, that a
matrix, that likelihood modality would
look like this. When we start
factorizing things or splitting up the
hidden state factors into an X factor
and a Y factor, that choice not only
manifests in the B arrays, but it also
manifests in the structure of the
arrays. And I think this is one of the
most key things to understand, because
when it comes to coding these things up
yourself, understanding how these arrays
are structured is really important to
getting things working successfully,
basically getting used to
multidimensional indexing. So briefly,
in summary, when you have multiple
hidden state factors that manifests as
extra Lagging dimensions or extra higher
order dimensions in your, in your
A array, so it's not really an A matrix
anymore, it's an A tensor. So that means
if you have two hidden state factors,
the number of Lagging dimensions, ie.
Excluding rows, that's what I mean when
I say Lagging dimensions will be two.
So you have columns and slices in
addition to rows. So this is really
important to understand when either
using SPM or Pymdp to do palm DP based
active inference. And another way of
saying this is for each additional
random variable that we're conditioning
our observations on, we have an
additional Lagging dimension in our
array. So this is the same principle as
with the B matrices because we condition
the next state both on the past state
and the past action. That's why the B
arrays are also tensors. So we have two
extra dimensions in the B array, one for
each conditioning variable, past state
and past action. So now in the X and
Y factorized grid world, we have two
Lagging dimensions where the first
Lagging dimension, the columns in Bleu,
index a particular X location, and the
second Lagging dimension, the slices,
if you will, index a particular Y
location. So now what I'm going to do is
unwrap these slices of the multi
dimension A matrix.
And so you can see that each slice of
the A matrix, so that each purple
indexed third order slice corresponds to
conditioning on a particular setting of
Y. So a particular conditional
distribution over observations for the
three settings of X for a fixed value of
Y. So each slice is exactly this
conditional distribution, where we're
looking at the conditional distributions
over observations for each setting of X.
So those are the columns indexed by the
Bleu numbers at the bottom, but we're
fixing to one value of Y. So that's the
conditional distribution over
observations zero, one and two. So being
in the top row, given that we're in the
first row, y equals zero for the three
possible settings of X. And then we move
down to the next set of observations and
the next slice of Y, and it looks like
that and then finally like that.
So this is the case where our
GPS is noiseless and high fidelity,
right? That's why we have like hyper
dark cells and then everything else is
white, is because the agent believes
that its observations are high fidelity
signals of the actual hidden state,
namely the X comma y location. So then
when we pat these back together, we see
how this full a matrix or set of
conditional distributions will be
represented by a nine by three by three
tensor, where again, each Lagrange
dimension exists to encode the
conditional dependencies between that
particular hidden state factor indexed
by the Lagging dimension and the
observations for this modality. So when
I index into the Ith column and the Jth
slice of this a matrix or a tensor, I'm
basically slicing out a particular
conditional distribution over
observations where I'm deciding what
settings of the conditional
distributions or the conditional random
variables I'm interested in.
Okay? So yeah, that's a kind of critical
concept and to just make it more
tangible and clear. And to be clear,
this isn't the only way to encode
conditional dependencies in categorical
distributions, but it's just the way
that was originally used in SPM to
encode these dependencies. And then we
just borrowed that convention when
building Pine VP. And it's pretty useful
because it makes generating things like
conditional expectations pretty
straightforward using linear
algebra operations like higher order dot
products and stuff like that. So we have
this kind of unwrapped representation
of the Ara here, and we can use this to
refer back to when we're building our
Ara. One thing I didn't mention that
is also important is that in the same
way we can factorize hidden states, we
can factorize modalities. So we'll talk
about that in a second. But just for
now, let's assume we have one single GPS
sensing modality of nine possible levels
where I am in grid world. So it's just a
list of one number nine, and then the
number of modalities will trivially be
one the length of that list. And then we
can use similarly this utils initialized
MTA array, which takes the number of
observation modalities, their
dimensions, and the number of hidden
states and then it creates the
A array with the proper dimensions and
everything. So I've also created this
combined list called a location dims,
which is a combination of the number of
observation modality dimensions and the
number of hidden state factor
dimensions. So that's, as we said,
going to be nine, three, three. And so
then we can populate the
entry of our first modality in the A
matrix, which is trivially here, the
only modality with a matrix of zeros.
This is actually what's happening under
the hood in this thing. So we don't need
to do it here. But then if we just run
that, then we'll see that the shape of a
zero is the same as a location dibs.
Okay, so that's just initializing it.
So we now have one A array that has one
modality whose shape is nine by three by
three. And then we just go and fill it
out like we saw up here. So I'm filling
it out under the assumption of this
noiseless high, high quality GPS sensor.
So you can see when I'm indexing into
the Lagging dimension here, the the Y
dimension, which is the third dimension
of the tensor. I'm saying for this
particular value of Y, which is when Y
is zero, we're in the first row
of grid world. Then the conditional
distribution over the three settings of
the GPS, given all the settings of X,
is just an identity matrix. So I'm just
coding that, that little chunk right
there. And then we can go through each
of the slices iteratively and do that.
So, yeah, one of the things I think is a
disadvantage currently of both Pine DP
and the SPM is I think we need better
ways to make people not have to do these
multi dimension indexing operations to
encode a particular conditional
independency structure. And I've thought
of ways to do that, but it's actually
pretty hard to do that in a generic
flexible way where people can just come
to the table with their own semantics
and then all this gets done for them.
So for now, you still have to kind of do
this by hand or write some algorithmic
way to do it that's specific to your
task. But yeah, that's just something to
mention. It's not ideal that we have
users doing this, but at the moment I
can't really think of a better way to do
it. And then once we've encoded that,
we can look at our little conditional
distributions given different settings
of Y. And that's just one choice. We
could also condition on X and look ant
for all settings of Y, x equals zero.
Like you can slice this up however you
want, right? That's just
a visualization choice.
And these are our three collections of
conditional distributions, one for each
setting of Y. Okay,
now let's go back to the slides.
Yes. So one thing I didn't mention, or I
said I would mention, is we just had a
single observation modality. But just as
for hidden states, we can factorize and
we don't have to fully enumerate our
observation space. So we could separate
the grid GPS observations into an X and
a Y GPS. So now you're observing a pair
of different observations at any given
time, one X observation and one Y. So
just like we had a separate B array for
each hidden state factor, similarly we
now have a separate A array for each
observation modality. So we would
populate one big A object array with
these different modality specific A
arrays. So in this case, if we had X
observations and Y observations, we
would have two A sub arrays. Each one
would have size three by three by three
because three observations and then for
the two possible states of the hidden
states factors. So, yeah, that wraps
up the slides I had on multifactor
multimodality factorized representations
and how that affects A and B arrays.
So before we move on to the contextual
multi arm bandit, let's open it up for
questions or comments if anything was
unclear and someone wants to contribute
their own way of explaining something,
happy to talk about that now.
Awesome. Yakup. Ben, adam and Karl, if
you'd like.
JAKUB SMEKAL: Yeah, thanks a lot for the great
overview. I had a question on
initializing the B matrix. So in this
case, we initialized it with the
simplest policy, just all of the
available actions the agent has.
Would there be any particular use case
in the grid world example where we would
want to initialize it with a sequence of
policies? And is that needed if we want
to do planning of different temporal
depth?
So when you say sequence of policies,
can you give me an example.
Instead of conditioning
it on, just move up, you would move
up and down fixed
sequences of actions.
Right, right. That's interesting. Okay,
so that's so, yes, typically when we are
building these cognition likelihoods,
this is more of a consequence of the
fact that it's a palm pom DP with
an emphasis on the M, so it's Markov.
So if you want to encode something like
what is the predicted next hidden state
given I did move up and
move down in the last two time steps?
If I'm understanding correctly, you're
like saying condition my B matrix, my
next hidden state on a sequence of two
possible past actions. Then we're
breaking the Markov property of the
dynamics because we're saying the next
hidden states not just depends on what I
did at the last time step and the state,
but it depends on also what I did two
time steps ago. So now you have a higher
order temporal dependence, like a semi
Markov model or yeah, really, just not a
Markov model, but a higher order model.
And that's not something that's
currently supported in Pamdp. The
natural way you get around that is by
building a hierarchical model.
So at each individual.
Level of the hierarchical you have a
palm DP, but then when you look at a
single layer, like the bottom layer of
this hierarchical model, it is a semi
Markov model or non Markovian. If you
take into account what all the other
layers are doing, but that's
not currently supported at the level of
a single Markov model. Like you can't
Bull a B matrix that's dependent on more
than what happened at the last time
step. You can't have an
extra lagging dimension that encodes
also what were they doing two time steps
ago? So that's one
interpretation of when you say policy
like up down, I think of two actions
that happened in sequence.
But maybe another thing, and correct me
if I'm reading too deeply into your
question, another thing would be can I
have actions in a different control
state factor affect the dynamics of a
particular hidden states factor? So say
I had one hidden state factor which is
move up, and another factor
which is Y displacement, another factor
that's X displacement. Can I have the
dynamics of the Y factor not just depend
on my Y action, but also on my X action?
So that's the idea of basically breaking
this independence property. Where is
it? Here, let me find it.
Here. So if you
allowed the lower right shows that the
state of one factor over time only
depends on the state of that factor ant
the previous time step. But if you said
I could also make this conditionally
dependent on not just
factor F, but say factor I or
Q at T minus one.
This is something that's also not
currently supported, but I think is an
interesting idea, which is you would
actually have interactions between maybe
pairs of hidden states factors in in
hidden states space. This actually can
be accommodated under PMDP.
Like mathematically I haven't built in
the functionality to do it, but I think
there's nothing that stops you in
principle from doing this. So this would
be as if I can have actions from
different control factors all
influencing the next state of one hidden
state factor. And that is
something that will probably make the
message passing a little bit more,
maybe not more complicated, but maybe
its convergence properties wouldn't be
as guaranteed. I don't know what it
looks because you're introducing weird
loops in your graph, but in the
factory graph that represents the
generative model. But that's something
in theory could be entertained. But I
don't know if that's actually what you
had in mind. Maybe you had more in mind
of breaking the Markov property when you
say conditioning on. Yeah,
thank you for the answer. It was more of
a clarification also on the mathematical
notation because pi
is interpreted as policy, which I guess
can mean both individual actions and
sequences of actions.
So just wanted to clarify that. Yeah,
that's a good point. So when I said pi
up here,
if pi was a sequence of ActInf lab.
Any given time, the B matrix that you're
indexing out is conditioned on the
action that's entailed by the policy at
that particular time. But the B matrix
will never be entailed on what's going
on in the full policy. But just by okay,
at time T, I take out this slice of the
B matrix because at time T, this is the
action entailed by this policy of
sequence length h or something. But
yeah, that's a good point. So in a
trivial case, policy length is one and
it's just one action that's the policy
is just an action that comes down to
slice out the B matrix.
Thanks yakub adam, anything you like to
add? Go for it.
ADAM GOLDSTEIN: Yeah, a couple of follow ups. Thank you for this very clear
presentation, Conor. So first, just to
follow on what Yakup just asked, it
seems like another potential way if you
wanted to do this sort of two times step
model would be to actually condense or
kind of permute those two time steps
into a single variable.
The same way that you could condense the
row and column into a single nine
dimension nine row vector, or you can
break it down into two. Could you
similarly Brea down the last two moves
and sort of combine them into a
permutation of all possibilities of the
last two moves and have those be the
hidden states? Yeah, you could do that
as well. I haven't seen that actually
done in practice. The only thing is
you'd actually have to somehow change
the scheduling,
I guess, of the message passing and the
action to accommodate the fact that
before I determine what my last hidden
state was, I need to wait two. Time
steps so I can get not only the proximal
action I did, but also have this memory
of the action two time steps ago. Yeah,
I was imagining that you'd have some
special case for the first move where
it's like undefined and then the last
move, then after that you'd have the
last two moves, a separate matrix for
those or something. Yeah, like a moving
window kind of so it's always
remembering the last. Yeah, I could see
that working. I think kind of
the canonical active inference answer to
that is instead of having to kind of
manufacture this special way of
basically baking memory into a Markovian
system, the classical way to handle that
is just to build a hierarchical model.
Because the hierarchical model handles
that memory easily by just having nested
Markovian processes where if you were to
look at a single process, it looks like
it has memory, but that's just because
its priors for its own Markovian process
are evolving as a function of another
palm DP that's operating at a slower
timescale. So I could imagine doing that
exact thing that you're talking about if
you had a low level palm DP that was
moving twice as fast as the top level
palm DP. And so basically, what the top
level palm DP is doing is setting an
initial prior over one action that then
allows this low level palm DP to
condition whatever it does next on a
belief that whatever I do next. I know
that I just took this action two time
steps ago, but you don't actually have
to handcraft that. It's just by building
one palm DP, like, within another palm
DP. But I don't see that there's
anything in principle going against what
you're describing as well.
I like your approach a lot better.
Yeah. Essentially what I learned from
working with Karl was that anytime
you're trying to imbue a system with
more complex non Markovian memory, full
dynamics or higher order dependencies,
that's when it's the natural move, is to
go to a hierarchical model because it
kind of handles it all naturally.
So my next question is about what
you were sort of tweaking in that
formula just a couple of minutes ago,
where you were suggesting the
possibility that there could be feedback
loops between the hidden states. In
theory, but as currently implemented,
if I understood correctly, that's not
the case. The state of one of the hidden
variables or the state of one of the
hidden states depends only on.
The. Previous state of that hidden state
as currently hidden factor.
What I want to make sure I understand is
that is that also something about
the Markovian assumption, or is that
just sort of an implementation or design
decision completely separate from the
Markov? Yeah, that's a good
question. That's separate from the
Markov separate from the Markovian
assumption. So that's something having
to do with kind of just how the graph
that represents the generative model,
which you could think of as like a
Bayesian graph, like a bunch of nodes
that affect a layer of observations.
So you say a bunch of hidden states
nodes, that all
the observation nodes conditionally
depend on the state of all the hidden
states factor nodes. By constructing it
this way, you basically have a graph
that it's very easy to do coherence on
that has like, stationary fixed points,
so the inference does not depend on
individual conditions of the posteriors
and things like that.
The way the generative model is set up
right now is like a bipartite graph that
resembles a classic model
for machine learning called like a
restricted Bellman machine. So this is
where all the hidden states can all
affect one observation modality,
but there's no interactions between the
observation layers, so there's no lines
going between observations within one
modality, and there's also no lines
going between hidden state factors. So
that's kind of one of the advantages of
this assumption, is when you have the
hidden state factors be only dependent
on their own past state and their own
past action within that control factor,
then you're not introducing these loops
in the graph that make inference a
little bit harder. So you'll see this
structure when people are using like
restricted Bellman machines or other or
even deep neural networks, it's very
hard to get fixed point solutions for
the posteriors when you have
interactions between nodes in a single
layer. So it's not quite the same thing
as yeah, it's just not the same thing as
the Markov property has more having to
do with generating an acyclic graph so
you can do a fast, efficient and fixed
point coherence on it. That's my general
answer to that. Because if you actually
draw out the factor graph for these
things, it looks like that. But there
might be another reason this is done
that I'm actually not aware of. Maybe
that's something that Karl would know or
someone else.
If you want to add anything, Karl,
otherwise and then after this we'll head
into the script. Go for it, Karl.
KARL FRISTON: Thank you. Yeah, I think everything that
needs to be said has already been said
very clearly and very usefully. But yes,
Conor, Heins absolutely right. So I
look at this in terms of the overall
architecture of the graphical model you
bring to the table and it can only have
a number of different attributes. How
deep is it? How many levels does it
have? We're not in this presentation
talking about deep MDP
or Joy to models based upon
hierarchically composed Markov
decision processes. But generally
you would think of any one level in the
context of the level above and the level
below, and that lends this attribute of
depth to any given generative model.
But probably more important, certainly
from the point of view of the current
discussion is the breadth. And the
breadth basically the number of
conditional independent factors.
In physics, this is simply known as the
mean field approximation. It's just a
factorization of a joint distribution.
In this instance, what we're aiming for
is an approximate post state
distribution. But it's a factorization
into conditionally independent factors
that incidentally, also induces certain
Markov blanket and resolves all of the
message passing and means that sort of
variational iterations are more robust.
But from the point of view of why do you
do that? Well, you do that because to
maximize the marginal likelihood of the
evidence for your generative model, you
have to carve the nature out there at
its joints in the right kind of way. So
if the world you're trying to navigate
or exchange with or explain does have
this factorization, these conditional
independences, it is carved in this way,
then your model has to comply in order
to have the maximum evidence. So when
learning that particular factorization
or that structure, you would normally
apply a process of basic model selection
or structure learning to get the number
of factors right, and that is getting
the right kind of meanwhile
approximation ant for this world and
these data. And the right factorization
will simply minimize the variation of
free energy and therefore minimize the
computational complexity and also the
computational complexity expressed in
terms of thermodynamics for example. So
it's a really important sort of thing.
Just a couple of little endorsement
comments.
Conditioning any one state with any one
factor on states and other factors
destroys that particular factorization.
So you don't have to worry about
introducing loops and things. All you're
doing is saying that particular
factorization has gone away, you've
coarse grained and you now have to lump
together all the elements of one factor
and the other factor into one bigger
factor. And now you've got a more coarse
grained factorization and a more
mathematically complex model because you
haven't done as many carvings to
leverage the conditional independences
that you're trying to model. And the
first question about the policies, that
was an interesting one, and I suspect it
may be an artifact of the way that we
condition everything on pie without sort
of forewarning people. Pi is actually
quite a complicated variable. First of
all, it's basically an index or a name
for quite a complicated combination of
things. So not only is it a sequence of
actions upon which you condition
each individual transition at any point
in time, over time, so it's a sequence
of action. So in answer to Yakub's
question, the whole point of the
expenditure energy is exploring lots and
lots of different sequences as you roll
out into the future,
but also induced by the factorization.
As Conor was saying,
that pie actually has to now entail an
action for every factor of a
fixed combination. So if you change the
combination of action, the two factors,
you now have a different policy even at
one time step, even for one step ahead.
So the notion of a policy as a
combination of actions is still in play
when you have a factorized.
Meanwhile, approximation of the hidden
states, it's a subtle point,
usually would resolve it by actually
explicitly writing down, using the
variable U, the thing that you're
conditioning the state transitions on.
And then U comes from
a family of combinations of use over
factors and over time. So you can have
deep and shallow policies, but you've
got very shallow policies one step ahead
and one look ahead policies. There's
still a subset of communication of
actions. So it could be that you can
either only move up or down
sorry, up or to the left, but you can't
move diagonally, for example, and that
will be placed in terms of priors over
pi, namely combinations of actions.
So one final, just for Adam's benefit,
that notion of putting
semimarkovian dynamics and Collins
absolutely right.
As a physicist, the way you do that is
by appealing to the depth of the
hierarchical model, which always entails
time. And that's an absolutely crucial
observation. There's no point in adding
depth to a generative model unless you
are mindful it is introducing a
separation temporal time skills. I think
that's a profound sort of structural
insight into the nature of generative
models and has all sorts of
implications. But then you're just
speaking to this notion of having
combinations or little histories or
little caches of legacy states as
if you like a superstate. Strictly
speaking, that is exactly what is done
effectively in continuous state space
model with Kalman filters. So you
actually have now two kinds of random
variables the position and the velocity.
So you've now got a sort of dual
representation. And if you generalize
that, you get to generalize quantum
motion. And technically
when you're doing variational message
passing, you now use something called a
chef, a free energy as opposed to which
is a variant of variation free energy.
However, when you move to discrete state
spaces, those generalized coordinates
now actually are replaced just by having
states that unfold in time over the
probability transition matrix. So that
you shouldn't in principle ever need to
do that. But you can now regard the
little local history, the little packet
or trajectory orbit the path that you're
taking at this point at this temporal
scale as sufficiently discrete and Clark
brain with the different probability
transition Atreides and then at the
slower tank scale, then it's a
succession of initial states. That's
normally how we would think about that,
but it's an interesting game to think
about Hohwy what kinds of structures in
these discrete states based models echo
the equivalent moves would have to make
in continuous state space modeling and
thinking here, particularly of
generalized filtering and Bayesian
smoothing and basic filtering and the
like.
Yeah, thank you. It's really nice to
have those afterthought because that
clarifies, I think, and justifies a lot
of the preceding slides, what Karl just
said. Yeah.
So you can kind of map the depths of the
hierarchy. Think of the depths of the
hierarchy as a discretion of what is
smoothly handled with generalized
filtering and generalized coordinates of
motion. So states evolving at this palm
DP are kind of like a quasi velocity
variable because they are evolving
slower than the position variable,
which is like the low level, quicker
clock palm DP. One just
tiny footnote there is it relates to the
continuum and differentiable free energy
landscape and the inclination that is
required on Modern digital hardware
around sampling and the inclination
problem on a continuous
but hidden function and the
approaches that we have to take to
discretize the continuous nature of time
especially.
Okay, so I
think we should proceed to the multi
armed bandit. Okay.
So now, having discussed these kind of
factorized representations, we're in a
position to build our multi factor
generative model for what I'm calling a
contextual two armed bandit or
contextual multi armed bandit. This is
coming from the reinforcement learning
literature. This term counterfactuals,
but it's based directly on a kind of
gambling task that was introduced in
Ryan Smith, Christopher White, Carls
Friston's, step by step tutorial and
active inference. So you basically have
a multi arm bandit, two arm bandit. But
you have to first find a clue or
forage information to figure out which
of the two slot machines or arms of the
bandit is more favorable. And this is
echoed as well in the original T Maze
example where you have a rat that has to
choose between two arms. One is more
rewarding than the other, but you don't
know which one is rewarding. So you have
to visit an informative Q state first
that tells you the left one is rewarding
right now or the right one is rewarding.
So I'm just kind of gathering all these
things into the term contextual bandit
because that's kind of the analogous
term for this problem that you'll find
in reinforcement learning world.
Okay,
so in the multi arm bandit or two armed
bandit task, an agent has to play,
choose to play one of two slot machines
and they can only play one at a time.
So one of the slot machines gives more
reward than the other, but the agent
doesn't know which is the better one.
So Anthony G. Chen time the agent can
choose to play the left or the right
machine. That's what we'll call them.
Or it can choose to ask for a hint. And
if it chooses to ask for a hint,
instead of playing the machine, it
receives information about which of the
two slot machines is better. So this
already sets up the basic dilemma of
tasks like this, the so called Explore
explore dilemma. So you first forage for
information that will ultimately lead to
getting more reward or do you gamble
immediately in order to get reward
sooner, but at the risk of not having
enough information to know which slot
machine I should actually play. So to
encode this task structure into a
generative models for a Palm DP, we
equip the agent with three observation
modalities. First, we have this hint
modality which is the sensory channel
the agent uses to perceive the hint. So
just what is the state of the hint?
Then there's a reward modality which
tells the agent whether it won or lost
at the selected machine. And then
finally there's a choice modality which
is just the agent's proprioceptive
conversation of its own choice. This is
equivalent to the GPS modality that we
were working with in gridworld. In terms
of hidden state factors, we first have a
context factor which is a binary
variable encoding which slot machine is
the more rewarding one. Either the left
machine is better or the right machine
is better. So those are the names of the
two context variables. You could just
arbitrary enable them like context A,
context B or something like that. And
then we have a choice hidden state
factor which is simply encoding the
choice state that the agent currently
occupies. And finally, as Karl was just
explaining, for each hidden state
factor, you also have a control factor.
So we'll have a context control factor,
which as we'll see, is trivial since the
agent can't control the context in this
particular simulation and a choice
control factor which is the control
factor that allows the agent to model
its own actions or choices.
So even for a shallow policy horizon,
as Karl was explaining, a policy will
still be comprised of two actions. So
there'll be a context action and a
choice action. But as we'll see, the
context action will always be to do
nothing or basically to not be able to
interfere in the dynamics of the context
hidden state factors. So basically
action selection comes down to just
choosing the state of the choice control
factor that you choice variable. So now
we're going to look at the different
levels of the hidden states factors. So
as we said, the context one is a binary
or you could think of it as like a
Bernoulli variable. So it's either left
better, right better, it's a
distribution over these two states of
the context and this is just the
unchanging state of the world for a
particular trial. Either left machine
has a better payoff probability or the
right one does. And then the choice
hidden state factor has four levels
which correspond to the four possible
choice states that the agent can be in.
So this can either be the neutral
starting location, the hint state which
is the location they occupy when they're
acquiring the hint, or they can be
playing the left machine or they can be
playing the right machine. And so now
for the control state factors. The
control state factor for the context
only has one level. You can call it do
nothing or it's just a trivial one
dimensional variable and the agent will
always take this action with 100%
probability. So in other words, the
agent has no control over the state of
the context and then the choice control
state has four levels corresponding to
the decision to change the S choice.
The hidden states factor for the choice
state in one of four different ways.
Either it can move to the start
location, it can move to the hint
location, it can play the left machine
or it can play the right machine. So
what choice state the agent is in is
kind of obviously under the agent's
control which is encoded by the fact
that this u choice variable has four
levels. So optimizing a posterior
distribution over this choice control
state factor, that's what action
selection and planning boils down to is
basically choosing what level of you
choice or inferring what the
distribution over you choices and then
sampling or taking the arg max of that
distribution to actually make an action.
Okay, so now let's review the
observation modalities and their
different levels. The first modality is
the hint modality which can either give
the outcomes of null like I'm not at the
hint state so I'm getting no sensory
information from that channel. A left is
better hint hint left or a right is
better hint and they're just named that
because we'll see in the A matrix how
seeing that observation relates to
seeing the, to the state of the context.
We have the no observation because as I
said, if the agent isn't in the choice
state of getting a hint, it still needs
to receive some information from that
modality. So that's why we often have in
both the SPM and the Pine VP
implementations we have this null
observation that just encodes an
observation that has no
information about hidden states within
some particular factor. And then we have
a reward modality which similarly has a
null observation for when the agent
isn't playing either slot machine and
then two possible reward observations,
either a loss or a reward. But this is a
choice that can depends on what you're
trying to do. You could also make O
reward have like ten different reward
levels that have different magnitudes of
reward. It's just a choice to call these
like loss and reward. The point being
that one is preferred relative to the
other. And then finally we have the
choice modality which just allows the
agent to unambiguously infer what choice
state it's in. So it just allows it to
infer what it's doing. And this is
important because remember active
inference lab, everything has to be
inferred. Everything is in the
game of minimizing free energy and
coming up with posteriors approximate
beliefs about the state of the world,
including your own choice state. So
that's why we often equip agent with a
proprietive sense of where I am like a
GPS.
That's the three observation by. We've
done the hidden states and the controls.
So now we're in a position to start
building the arrays for this agent's
generative model. So for each modality
specific array we're going to have as
many rows as there are levels of that
modality and then two columns and four
slices. And so why is it two columns,
four slices? Because each column
corresponds to a setting of the context
hidden state factor and each third order
slice corresponds to a setting of the
choice state hidden state factor. And
these lagging dimension of two columns,
four slices will be the same for every
single A matrix, not the values in them,
but that shape. So the only thing that
will change across modalities, the A
modality specific A arrays is the number
of rows, which is the number of
observation levels. So for the hint
modality, each slice of this A matrix
tells us the mapping between the two
possible context states and the
observations in the hint modality for a
fixed choice state that the agent could
be in. So, for instance, if the agent is
in the start choice state, what we're
seeing now regardless of whether the
left or the right mission is better,
the agent will always get the null
observation, which has zero information
about the state of the context, as you
can see, because given an observation
of the null observation in the hint
modality, you have no idea whether the
left is better or the right is better.
However, if the agent is in the visit a
hint state or acquire a hint state,
then the mapping between the concept
state and the two hint observations will
be informative. And when I say
informative, I just mean that the
columns of this matrix will be
independent from each other and they
will be low entropy. So another way of
saying that is that they'll be low
entropy in the observation conditioned
rows of the matrix. So briefly what
we're seeing here, where grayscale
darker colors means more probability,
if the slot less machine is better
that's the context, then the agent is
more likely to see the hint left
observation. And if the right machine is
better, they're more likely to see the
hint to right observation. So this slice
of the a matrix is what gives those
observation levels their meaning. The
very reason they're called hint left and
hint right is just because of the kind
of diagonal structure in this slice of
the matrix. And then finally for the
other states, if I'm playing the left or
the right machine, I'm never getting any
informative observations from this
modality. Okay?
And then we move on to the reward
modality. So again, two columns and four
slices like for all the arrays. But now
we're looking at the mapping between the
two context and the reward observation
levels. So Bull lost reward for each
possible choice state the agent could be
in. So as we can see if the agent is in
starting location or getting the hint,
they're not getting any reward
conversation, they get the trivial,
meaningless null observation. However,
if the agent is playing the left or the
right machine, there's a probabilistic
mapping between the context, the left
machine or the right machine being
better and the expected reward. So if
the context is left is better, then the
agent is more likely to see the reward
if and only if they're playing the left
machine. Likewise, if they're playing
the right machine, this matrix is the
same. So if you're playing right, then
you're more likely to see reward. So
this submatrix within this big a tensor
is what determines the payoff structure
of the task or
the agent's beliefs about that payoff
structure, I should say, because this is
the array, it's not the actual rules of
the game. So now we're finally up to the
choice modality which again is just
their observation of their own choice
state which you can see only depends on
the state of the choice that they're
making. It doesn't depend on the
context. So it just means that they'll
always unambiguously infer whether
they're playing the right machine or
they're in the start state or whatnot.
So this is just an example of going
through those slices and really seeing
how that looks. So now we can code this
up in Colab. And again, we won't be
doing it by hand,
we'll just be running some predefined
code. So one useful thing to do often
with control factors and observation
modalities is get some semantic labels
like create a list of strings for
instance. So the context names will have
these two states left better, right,
better choice names will have these four
possible states. And then we can
automatically create these lists of
dimensions that are needed to create
your A and B matrices just by looking at
things like the length of this list of
strings or the length of this list of
choice names. So if you run this,
then we'll have our NUM states variable,
which will be 24 two possible contexts
and four possible choice states. And
then you'll have numbs, which will be
three possible hints, three possible
rewards and four proprioceptive location
or choice state observations. And then
we can use this function to initialize
our empty A matrix and then the next few
chunks of code basically just fill out
these A matrices like we saw in the
slides. So one thing we'll
do is we'll have two parameters and this
is again arbitrary. You can choose to do
this however you want. We'll prioritize
the A matrix with a probability of hint
or a hint accuracy which will
effectively just fill out that slice of
the hint modality array that corresponds
to how accurately the hint signal
indicates the concept or lends evidence
to the concept. So if the Hinton is 1.0,
p hint is 1.0, it means whenever they
visit the hint state, they immediately
know, okay, the left arm is better, but
this doesn't have to be 100% right? The
hint itself could have some noise or
uncertainty associated with it. So we'll
parameterize that just with this
probability. So this is
the probability of the two hint types
for the two game states. And you see the
null has zero probability and then hint
left has more probably when the context
is left indicated by the column. And
then hint right has more probability
when the context is right. And then
we'll just go through and fill out this
chance stuff. Oh, the reward modality
will have a similar thing of P reward.
So this will determine the payoff
structure of both bandit arms. So if P
reward is high, it means if the context
is left is better and you're playing the
left slot machine, you'll have an 80%
chance of getting the reward. And this
thing itself can be changed to determine
basically how how rewarding the bandits
are.
So this is the payoff structure if
you're playing the left arm, the payoff
structure for the two contexts. And
there's an inverseness that I didn't
discuss. So if I'm playing the left arm
but the right arm is better, then I'm
also more likely symmetrically to get
punishment or negative reward with the
same probability that I would get
positive reward if I was playing the
right on so that's also a choice but
just to make this a single parameter.
That's how we did it here. And then
finally the choice observation by that
is just filling out that GPS high
fidelity GPS sensor.
If you slice it along any context
hidden states factor, since it doesn't
depend on context, this could be a zero
or a one. Then we'll get an identity
mapping which just allows them to infer
their choice state and then we wrap this
all into one function. So we just have
two parameters p Hinton, p reward and
then we can see once we start doing
simulations how manipulating those
things messes with their behavior.
So now we'll move on to the B arrays.
Oh yeah, so let me go here and talk
through some slides. This will be quick.
The brain are pretty simple so we're
going to mess with this later. But we're
going to start by saying that the
context hidden states factor is
stationary over time so they can't
change that hidden state factor and even
in the absence of their ambiguity to
intervene, it stays
in the same state over time. So we
parameterize this with like a p change
probability that just fills out the
diagonal of this kind of trivial
transition matrix with 100% probability.
But later on we can mess with that
parameter and decrease it. So they
believe that the concept can actually
change with some stochasticity over
time. But for now we just assume
they don't believe the context changes
and then this is their ability to so
unlike Grid World where you have local
actions, they can only move up, down,
left, right here. They can move from any
other state to any other state. So this
is like a signature or thing if you want
a controllable hidden state space. So
the agent can go anywhere from any other
place that will manifest as these dark
bands in your b matrix or bands of 100%
probability. So this is another way of
saying that the transition graph is
fully connected, that you can get
anywhere from anywhere. But that's
also not sure we could have made it such
that once they leave the start state
they can't return there. So that would
correspond to having the absence of one
of these. Like basically the start state
is a source but it can't also be a sync
or there's no in arrows going to it so
that would affect the structure of this.
Okay and then we can quickly code that
up.
So b zero is the concept hidden states
which as we said is just going to be
stationarity and then the choice hidden
states is fully controllable and then we
will parameterize this all as a create B
function which will for now have this p
change thing. So we can make the agent
belief about the stationary of the
context different. Like if the context
is likely to change, but for now, by
setting it to zero, it just means that
they believe the context is fixed for a
given trial or set of time points.
And then finally, very basic. Stuff.
This is just how we establish the
semantics of the reward modality. So the
reward modality is, as we said, the
null, the loss and the reward. And we
can encode the C vector, which is kind
of like the reward function,
the prior preferences or prior over
observations directly in terms of
relative log probabilities. So we can
encode punishment by having the prior
expectation about loss be much lower in
relative log in natural
log units. Much. Lower than the reward
observation within that modality. And
then the other ones are just going to be
uniform distribution, so you can leave
them empty. And this is just what
allows them to want to see reward as
opposed to loss or punishment.
I think we discussed this last time.
Daphne had a question about that. So why
do we encode things in relative log
probabilities rather than sheer
probabilities? It's just more analogous
to the reward construct from
reinforcement learning that's one
benefit and they're unbounded. They
don't have to be bounded between zero
and one. So if you just encode them that
way, it becomes easier to kind of make
one thing x times more rewarding or
punish or aversive than another thing.
And that directly relates to how kind of
reward is calculated in our expected
utility of the expected free energy is
because it's always kind of an expected
it's kind of like an entropy or a cross
entropy. So its units are
in natural log space.
Okay. And then the D vector.
Again, they can have prior beliefs about
which context is better. So that will
also be a collection of vectors, one
over the context factor and one over the
initial state of where they are, which
we can make it start, but it doesn't
really matter because they have precise
observations. And then that's very easy
to do in prime DP. We'll just create
some functions that parameterize how
rewarding the reward observation is and
how punishing the punishment observation
is. Then we can plot those and this
could be ten. Then the
reward is much more is much better
than the punishment, or the punishment
could be very bad, in which case the
punishment is much, much lower than both
the null and the reward. And here
I'm showing the prior directly in terms
of probabilities. So when you convert
the log probabilities to probabilities,
these things will become bounded between
zero and one. Okay?
And then the D vector simulator will
just create a quick function that
parameterizes how much they believe the
left is better. Context is true at the
beginning of the simulation. And if you
just set that to 0.5, it means they have
flat, unbiased, uninformed prior beliefs
about the concept.
Yes. Okay.
All right, so now I think we are good to
actually do this after all the build up.
So, like 95% of the work is encoding the
generative model. And this is something
Karl will tell you as well. SPM most of
the work is not actually running active
inference. Maybe computation wise it is,
but in terms of the time and the
intellectual energy spent, it all comes
down to the generative model. That's
where all the information is. The rest
is just optimization, basically. So
we've written down our ABCs and DS,
then we just basically plug them into
this agent API from Pinedp. And then we
create an environment class which could
be as something as ad hoc as I'm getting
a list of observations from some API
that's talking to the Internet or from a
robot sensors. Or you can actually write
down an environment class that generates
observations like another agent, for
instance. And then you plug the
observations from the environment into
the infer states function you do infer
policies. And then you sample an action
according to the expected free energy
stuff that we talked about last time.
Okay, so now we're actually going
to do this. So we have our nice nifty
functions for creating A-B-C and D. We
can just run those with desired levels
of P hint and P reward and then create
our agent. And this is something we
discussed last time, but an important
distinctions is the generative model
versus the generative process or the
environment. So the things we're putting
in A and B right now and C are just the
agent's beliefs about, for instance,
the hint accuracy or the payoff matrix
of reward that can be arbitrarily
different from the actual structure of
the environment. And we'll see how later
we'll see how you can adjust. The agent
can actually learn the correct reward
statistics through a process of
learning. So even if they start out with
the wrong generative model, they can
adapt their generative model online so
that they match the generative process
better. Okay, and then we'll define
this quick class, the two arm bandit,
which will be the generative process,
the real world for our agent. We're not
going to step through the code, but the
link is available. So if anyone wants to
look at this, this is basically just
encoding the rules of the game. So when
the agent is in the left arm, they'll
get reward or Costa, depending on the P
reward and P hint values. And as we
said, these values can be different than
the agent's beliefs about them, which
will be in their A matrix. So this is
the generative process, the actual
reward, and then the generative models
are the parameters you give to the A
Constructor.
And then we'll just have a function here
that runs the active inference loop. It
looks a little bit more complicated than
those three lines I showed on the slide,
but that's just because I'm storing
things like the history of their
choices, the history of their beliefs.
I'm having optional plotting of beliefs
things like that and plotting of
actions. But this function basically
the key things are you get an
observation from the you start with an
observation, which it will be from the
generative process. You do hidden state
inference using that observation to get
your posterior over hidden states. And
this you can return if you want to plot
it, but you don't have to. And then
you'll do inference about policy. So
this is optimization of a posterior over
policies, which then gets translated
into marginal posterior over control
states or action that you sample from
and you sample from them if this next
line with sample action. So the main
three lines of any active coherence
process are inference about states,
coherence about policies, and then
action selection, which can be either
deterministic or stochastic depending on
your application. And then the rest is
just basically code that converts
observations from the generative process
into the terms that the agent can
understand and vice versa. And then we
have this helper function that plots the
history of choices and beliefs and the
true context over time.
So, yeah, I just blaze through that
quickly because it's not very important,
but if anyone has questions, we can go
back and dissect that code a little
more. So now all we have to do
is define the yako. You have
your hand up, you'll ask. Something,
yeah, maybe this is
better suited for the end, but in
time DP, there's also modules that are
adjacent to the agent class.
So I was just wondering.
How we. Could make use of the different
modules in the action perception loop,
because I haven't seen many examples of
using, for instance, the inference
module or the learning module and how
that would augment the run active
infrastructure. Yeah, that's a great
question. So I have another demo that we
can maybe do another time that's
building a hierarchical model in PMDP.
So building a two layer model. It's a
visual foraging hierarchical model based
on a paper that we did back in 2018,
2019. And there you're
in this inner loop over time, you're
making use of these sub module
functions. So say you wanted to do some
special kind of inference that's not
just the standard infer states. You
could actually say, okay, I want to do
this particular weird thing that's
specific to this inference process. And
you would just add lines here like, I
want to take a function from the
inference module and run like, I don't
know, a different kind of message
passing on it, like run MMP or
something inference. Or there's an Algos
module too that has different message
passing algorithms. And then you could
optimize your hidden state belief,
updating that message passing algorithm,
and then set them equal to the
special thing you did just
with that.
So, yeah, there's no examples here,
but I haven't done that here, but it's
definitely something that can be done.
Or yeah, there's another example I did,
like simulating an active inference
equivalent of an evidence accumulation
drift diffusion style task where the
policy selection was done in a
particular way, where you're only using
certain components of the expected free
energy. And yes, so basically
there's other demos where you can,
like, zoom in and not use the Agent
class and use sub modules, but I haven't
written those in a publicly
accessible way yet, but the hierarchical
one I can just easily make public. I
just haven't had time to put it on the
dock yet. But yeah, that's a good
question because you're right, most of
the stuff right now is just the highest
level implementation with the Agent.
Okay? And now that to
just run the active inference process,
I've made a distinction between
generative process parameters, like how
accurate the hint is, how the payoff
structure is, and then generative model
parameters which are used when creating
the a matrix. So the p hint end is the
true hint accuracy p reward end is the
true payoff. And then just choose some
time horizon and run the active
inference soup with that time horizon
and then plot the history of beliefs.
Okay, so here's an example.
The top plot shows the Agent's behavior.
So white squares indicate what it was
doing at any given time. So time is on
the x axis. So you can see it start in
the start state. Then it gathered
information at the hint.
And the reason this wasn't immediate is
because its beliefs about accuracy were
only 0.7. So it needs to actually do
some evidence accumulation before it's
sure what active states is. Then it
played right. But as soon as it played
right, because that's what the hint was
telling it. As soon as it played right,
it probably had a
loss observation, which then messed up
its inference and made it go back to the
hint to accumulate evidence again before
being okay, the hint is really
suggesting that I should go, right? So
then it goes back, revisits the right
arm, and then over time, you see here,
the red dot is the actual true context,
and the gray scale indicates the Agent's
beliefs about the hidden states. So
here, the hidden states beliefs are now
converging to believing that the right
arm is better. And I know I said hit the
beginning that all probability would be
darker means higher probability, but
it's actually the opposite here, so
sorry, that's confusing. So yeah,
right. Better is higher probability,
and their beliefs get more and more
competent as they play. So this is the
exact same thing you'll see with the
teammates, right? They first forage for
information that's driven by this
epistemic value component to the
expected free energy. As their posterior
over hidden states becomes more precise,
epistemic value goes down, and then the
expected utility component goes up,
which is bolstered by the fact that they
now have confident beliefs about the
context. And then that drives them to
forge information.
And then so the kind of exercise that I
would have people do if this was like in
a classroom context is start messing
with the bandit probabilities and also
mess with the agent's sensitivity to
punishment. So up here, we made them
have plus two relative nats in their
reward function and minus four for
punishment. But if you made this even
lower, let's say you made it negative
six, what would happen?
So now, because they're more risk
Andersen the risk of getting
a loss observation, if I was to play,
immediately becomes higher. So now the
agent basically requires more confidence
before it's willing to actually play the
left arm, because the risk of getting it
wrong and getting a loss is too great
because their reward function is now
shaped more risk aversely.
And then if I decrease this even more
down to negative eight, you can see that
they never even go for playing. Because
even once they're very certain that the
left arm is better, it's still too
risky, given their beliefs about the
payoff structure because their beliefs
about the payoff structure are such that
they believe that there's still a 20%
chance that they'll get. Costa. But if
we change this and said what if their p
reward was 1.0 or,
say, zero point 99?
Then they're willing, even despite the
great risk of being punished because the
expected reward given, you know, the
context is high enough, they will still
end up risking it and they acquire the
hint for some time and then they start
risking it. But the observations will,
because peer is so high, their beliefs
about the payoff structure, their
beliefs will kind of oscillate as the
observations actually change, because
the true observations are generated much
more stochastically, because this is the
P reward of the bandit. So you can mess
around with this. And I would encourage,
if anyone listening now or afterwards
wants to mess with these parameters, I
would encourage you to just go crazy and
mess with parameters and see what
different kinds of behavior you can get.
Okay, so that pretty much wraps up the
main brunt of the entorhinal.
Let's pause there for questions because
I have additional material about
learning parameters that we discussed
last time would be good to get
into because that's something that's
really underdocumented right now with
PMDP. So we can move into
that. But I think we should first break
for some questions.
Awesome. Thank you. Jacob if you ant to
ask or Karl. Otherwise, I'm happy to
hear about learning. Cool.
Let's do learning and then we'll have
and closing questions at the end.
Perfect.
Okay, I'll have some quick slides. So
learning under active inference is cast
as updating beliefs about the generative
model parameters itself. So inference
is one thing. Inference is saying,
given my generative models, so my
beliefs about the way the world works,
what is the best explanation in the
sense of posterior over hidden states?
And policies that explains my actual
data. And you get that by minimizing
variational free energy. Learning
becomes much more complex but also more
interesting in the sense that if the
agent's generative model itself is
wrong, they can change the generative
model to also optimize variational free
energy. So learning and inference can
kind of cooperate or sometimes interfere
with each other as we'll see to minimize
variational free energy. So the way we
have to start by doing this is now
treating the parameters themselves. So
the parameters of the A array which are
categorical likelihood parameters, b
array, D array, CRA those themselves now
become random variables over which we
can have priors and of course
variational posteriors.
So we can go back to our original A or
palm DP representation. So now what we
see is in this third column next to
A-B-C and D we have parameters that are
priors over the categorical
parameters of the A-B-C and D. So a
natural prior for these sorts of
categorical variables is called the deer
schley distribution which is basically a
conjugate prior for a categorical
likelihood distribution. That's why it's
very nice and also the values of its
parameters have a very nice intuitive
feeling and interpretability to them.
So now the agents will have priors which
are updated by this p of Phi at the top.
And phi is just a collection of all
these deer schleich hyper parameters.
They're also called or prior parameters
and these are parameters or priors over
random variables that themselves are the
likelihood distinctions and priors of
the generative model. So we're just
going to do a few instances of learning
today. I don't know if we'll have time
to do B or D learning. We'll start with
a matrix learning but
the principle applies the same. So
here's an example of the deer slate
prior distribution over some categorical
parameters. So let's say our a matrix or
A array, let's just say it's a matrix.
So now the random variable itself are
the entries of the A matrix. A prior
over those entries is something called a
deer schley distribution which is just a
vector of positive real numbers. And
here we've reshaped it so that it has
the shape of an array. So let's say this
array represents like the payoff matrix
in our bandit task. So the two columns
or two possible hidden states are
context one, context two and then the
two observations are punishment and
reward. So if this is our prior which is
measured by these deer schley
parameters, the likelihood
distribution that they parameterisation
also you can express this as the
expected value of the deer sleigh
distribution is a categorical with these
values. So what you can see is that the
deer Shlay counts like the
kind of scalar magnitude of the deer
slate parameters kind of represent a
prior coherence about the probability of
of the different contingencies encoded
in the A matrix. So I made these, these
very simple here like the the
deer slate priors are nine counts for
seeing punishment given context and one
count for seeing reward given context
one. But you can change those to very
high numbers. So for instance, if that
nine on the left was changed to a
10,000, then on the right the
probabilities would become like 0.99 to
.00,001. So the scale of the deer
schley, also known as pseudo count
parameters, encodes something like a
belief about how many times that
particular coincidence of observation
and hidden state has been observed,
which you can also think of as like a
prior confidence about that contingency
and the expectation to create your A
matrix via this. Going from a deer slate
to an A array is very simple because you
just take each deer slate count and
divide it by the column wise sum, which
is this a not variable on the lower
right. So it's just that particular
value of the A array and divided by
the sum of the counts. So that's
how you go from a deer slate prior over
a categorical likelihood distribution
through the expectation and
then inference. And I'm not going to
guide into the variational posterior,
but it's very simple. So when you're
doing learning and you're trying to
actually update these Deer parameters as
a function of observations, what
essentially you have is a new posterior
that's now not over hidden states of the
world, but you have a variational
posterior over the parameters the
categorical or rather a variational
posterior over the deer distribution,
the deer slay distinctions that
parameterizes your a matrix. So that's
what's representing the lower right. So
let's assume that our beliefs about the
deer shay parameters were as it is now.
So your beliefs about the A matrix and
then we get an observation and let's say
that we saw the conversation of
punishment and that can be represented
by this one hot vector. Now we want to
update our beliefs about the A matrix
given the observation, but to do that,
what you also need is a hidden state or
a belief about hidden states. And let's
say that the agent was very confident
that the hidden state was concept one.
What ends up happening to the resulting
posterior over the A matrix is a very
simple associative, quasi associative
learning rule where the update to the
deer schley represented by this bold a
SUBQ becomes the prior over the deer
sleigh parameters plus the outer product
between the observation vector and the
hidden state belief vector. So this is
kind of like a form of coincidence
detection where you just see what parts
of the hidden states line up with what
parts of the observations and you
increment your beliefs about the A
matrix accordingly. So in this case, if
I really believe the concept was one and
I saw a punishment, then my belief about
that particular contingency seeing
punishment under context one would just
be incremented by a plus one.
And that's what this outer product at
the lower right calculates. It computes
a matrix that is the increment to your
beliefs about the A matrix. So in this
case, the matrix would be have one in
the upper left and then zeros in the
other three entries. And you use that to
kind of increment your A matrix.
Technically you're incrementing a deer
schley kind of conjugate prior over your
A matrix, but it's really
a variational deer schley posterior.
But you can imagine if your hidden
states are also contaminated with
uncertainty. So say you had 50%, you
were 50 50, whether it was concept one
or context two. Then similarly with this
a matrix update, the update would then
be spread over the two possible
contingencies. So if you saw an
observation but you weren't sure what
the hidden state was, then both just the
overall probability of seeing punishment
under your generative model would go up
because you would increment that entire
row of the A matrix within this case
0.5. So that's just an important thing
to note is that uncertainty in your own
hidden state beliefs will bleed into the
updates to the deer sleigh parameters
and oftentimes alongside,
I mean optimally alongside a matrix
learning or parameter learning. You're
also going to be augmenting your
expected free energy because your
generative models now different. So you
have these new priors and posteriors
with a so called parameter information
gain term or a novelty term. So while
you're pursuing learning, it also makes
sense to choose your policies such that
you'll maximize the
information you get based on the
consequences of your policies about the
parameters of the generative model. So
this expected KL divergence exactly
quantifies how much a given policy will
lead to a good Bayesian update of your
parameter beliefs. So intuitively this
quantity might be described as how much
do I expect the consequences of my
actions will update my beliefs about
parameters. So consequences of actions
is represented by that Q of O given pi,
the thing that the KL divergence is
taken under expectation of. And then the
actual KL divergence is saying how much
surprise will I get given these
observations relative to my current
beliefs about the parameters of the
generative model? So this is what's
called in the literature of the novelty
term and it's very easy to
experimentally turn off or on this
novelty term using simple flags in
the agent class. And this goes for the
other components of the variation or the
expected free energy as well. You can
kind of turn on flags that say do I want
to use this novelty or parameter
information gain? Do I want to use the
state info gain which is the same as the
epistemic value or the Bayesian surprise
and then do I want to use the utility?
So for the learning simulations, it
makes sense if you're doing learning to
make sure that this parameter is turned
on. Okay,
so. That's the kind of slides on
learning. And now we can actually get
into implementing this in Pinevp.
So we
first will create an A matrix and we'll
let the agent have very slight positive
beliefs about the reward contingencies.
And I'll explain later why this helps.
It helps with learning if they don't
have total ignorance about the reward
probabilities but they have some bias in
some direction. It doesn't actually have
to be zero point 51, it could be the
other way. And then there's utility
functions that allow you to create deer
schley variables that have the same
shape as some base A array. So here
this PA variable
is basically the prior that bold a SUBP
variable that represents the agent's
deer schleich prior over the A matrix.
So this is now a new variable that we're
going to pass in to the
agent Constructor. So if our A matrix is
like let's look at the reward
contingency, reward modality.
So that's a one. So this is the agent's
current beliefs about the payoff
structure, right? So under choose
left and choose right. Those are the two
contingencies. Given the two hidden
states, PA will have the same structure
except that it'll have those
contingencies encoded in terms of deer
sleigh pseudo counts. So if I made them
made the pseudo count scale ten,
then they're very relatively confident
that the payoff probabilities look like
this. But again, these are not
probabilities, they're deer slate
parameters that parameterize a
categorical likelihood. So you can use
the normalized distribution function to
actually then visualize the deer slate
distribution in terms of actual
categorical parameters. So taking
the expectation I e. The normalization
of the deer slay prior will give you
exactly this.
So if I say are these two things the
same? They should be the same. Okay,
maybe down to numerical differences,
they're not.
Okay? So yeah, that's how you
parameterize that. So we'll create this
is an important point that's also used
in SPM. Often we want certain
contingencies to be unavailable to
learning. So we assume these are
contingencies that are baked into the
agent's beliefs about the world and thus
not adaptable. So one way, and this is
just barred from the SPM way of doing
it, to encode that is to bake
in a kind of really precise
confidence or very high confidence that
certain contingencies are the case. And
you can just do that by adjusting the
scale parameter for particular indices.
For instance, by doing this I'm just
telling the agent that it essentially
doesn't learn the contingencies related
to the null modality. So for
instance, if you're in the
start state it believes with really high
confidence that you'll always get the
null observation. And we just
operationalize that by creating very
high pseudo count or deer sleigh priors
over that particular slice of the A
matrix. So that's an important point
to do. And then we'll just write all
this stuff. So this prior count about
the Bull observations and then the scale
that determines their general confidence
outside of this null thing. We'll write
that all into a function so that we can
then parameterize our PA. And then
we now write a new active inference with
learning loop where instead of just
storing the history of choices and
beliefs, we also store the history of
their beliefs about the Dean Shlay
parameters. And an important thing that
you can also do in PMDP, which is nice,
is you can say I only want to learn
particular modalities. So when you're
creating the agent class, there's a
bunch of arguments you can pass in, but
one of them is I only want to be
learning the reward payoff modality
right now. And this can change. You
could have them learn the hint accuracy
as well. But by passing in a list of
which of the modality indices that you
want them to learn, you turn off
learning on all the other modalities,
which normally in SPM or what we used to
have to do in pi MDP is. You just have
to turn up those deer slay pseudo counts
super high on all the modalities that
you don't want to learn. But if there
are other modalities that you don't want
to learn now you can just pass in this
list of modalities that you want to
learn and it'll only focus learning onto
that. So now I'm setting up an agent
that has these particular beliefs about
the world via A and now has a prior that
is going to update through doing
variational inference or learning.
And then so we'll create the generative
model here, including this new prior
over A and then we'll run the active
inference loop with learning which
involves creating an agent that can only
do learning on the payoff structure
modality. So we want the agent to now
learn which arm is best basically
because it doesn't know the payoffs and
then also to use parameter information
gain to motivate its decision. And
there's another thing I forgot to
mention, which is the learning rate,
which is how much they increment their
beliefs about the posterior
or about the A matrix using this update
rule. So there's something I didn't
mention. There's often a learning rate
that's added here that basically scales
how big this update is so that
you can experiment. It depends on the
application, what the scale of that is
going to be, but the default is one.
Okay, so in this example, the agent
gets the hint for one time step.
It's got the standard like negative four
punishment and then it goes straight to
the right because it believes the hint
is accurate. So it gets a reward is
right, then it goes and starts playing
the right arm and you see it's posterior
beliefs instantly go to right. And now
since what we've also spit out of this
active coherence group is the beliefs
about the A matrix in this QA
posterior over A history we can plot its
beliefs about the A matrix probability
over the contingency of seeing reward
given that I was in the right arm. And
what you see is that even though they
start with basically 50 50 beliefs as
they gather observations, their beliefs
about that posterior probability over
that particular energy of the A matrix
get bigger and bigger. An interesting
consequence of this is their beliefs
about the left arm contingencies don't
change because they don't ever
experience that state of the world.
So that's like an interesting, what you
might call in machine learning.
It's not really a bad bootstrap but it's
the idea of selective sampling. So you
only learn those contingencies that are
selective to the part of the world that
you're sampling so the agent doesn't
know what that other slice of the A
matrix looks like because it's never
experienced what it's like to be in the
left is better context and playing the
left arm. So it's posterior beliefs
about that part of the A matrix remain
the same but you can see that over time
its beliefs start to converge to zero
eight which is what we set in the
generative model. This is just basic
statistical learning, right? It's just
getting reward observations over time
and as it gets a sequence of reward and
punishment through this very associative
basic mechanism, it's just incrementing
its deer slay beliefs. And what I'm
showing is the normalized IED.
Expectation of those beliefs over time.
So you get something that's 0.8 but the
actual deer slay parameters themselves
will be growing like linearly in time
effectively depending on the
observations they get. Yeah, so that
is just the basic learning. And then
there's another thing you can do which
is take advantage of this change
probability. So now we allow the context
to change and this is one way to get
them to actually be able to explore and
learn more about both reward
probabilities in the landscape is allow
them to have not only to make the
environment change, but they also
entertain beliefs in their
B matrix that the environment can
change. So you could use this to do B
matrix learning as well by defining like
a PB variable but here we're just going
to have a matrix learning as we were
doing before. I've changed a little bit
the parameters to make things a little
more stable because sometimes you get
weird behavior. I mean that's something
we can play around with too. So now they
allow the environment itself can change
and they also in their B matrix they
think the environment can change. And
then I'll plot the history of
beliefs and choices. So now they
instantly go for playing the arms.
They kind of risk it. The parameter
information gain actually outweighs the
epistemic or state information gain.
They start playing, they gather
observations but they're not very
confident about what the state of the
world is because they only are getting
information about the hidden states from
the actual sequence of rewards and
losses. And then eventually they go to
the hint because probably the utility
becomes low because they don't know what
their reward probabilities are and
they're building their own beliefs.
Then they get the hint. Then the hint is
accurate. So they have very precise
beliefs about the hidden states of the
world and then the world actually
switches. So you see the red dot is the
actual switching statistics of the
bandit. And now they've kind of explored
both bandit arms while also updating
their beliefs about the bandits.
And you see that their beliefs about the
left arm are kind of bad because
it seems like they've probably mostly
gotten generative data while they're in
the left arm and they didn't explore it
very much. Or no,
I guess at the end they're exploring it
quite a bit, but their beliefs about to
go down because they have, I guess, a
bad experience with it.
Yeah, that's the left arm, that's the
right arm. But you can keep trying this
and mess around with different
parameters and you'll get different
sorts of beliefs.
So here in this example, there's some
switching going on. Their posteriors
aren't tracking very well until they
actually visit the hint and then their
posteriors start getting much more,
much more precise. And then at that
point they can start making more precise
beliefs. In this case, they ended up
kind of doing poorly on learning on both
of them because the true reward
probabilities are P eight. Yeah.
So everything I've talked about so far
is an example where learning can often
lead to suboptimal outcomes because it's
done in an online fashion. So this is an
interesting point of departure between
SPM and PMDP, but you can do all the
same things in SPM that you can do in
Pimdp. So here what I'm doing is I'm
updating the A matrix every time I get
an observation. So they do hidden state
coherence, they select policies,
they select actions, and then given the
last observation and the last hidden
state belief, they do one step of
parameter inference and then they use
the next A matrix. That's what's handled
in this update, a function of the agent
class. They update their beliefs about
the A matrix and they use that for
inference at the next time step.
Another way you could do this is you
could do an entire trial and then update
your A matrix at the very end of all the
time steps of action selection and
observation sampling and then use that A
matrix for another trial. So this is
kind of the difference between a
more em separation
of timescales em or expectation
maximization approach where given a set
of observations, then I update my model
and then I go back and I do more trials
without updating my model but using the
same fixed one. And then you can kind of
do that in epochs and that's typically
how it's done in SPM because you only do
parameter learning basically this part
outside this time loop. So you do it
like down here, but then what you do is
you run multiple trials. And the nice
thing about that is it kind of makes the
A matrix updates less likely
to in the moment bias your action
selection. So for a given set of time
steps, you're locked into what your A
matrix beliefs are and you don't do the
update until a set of time steps has
elapsed. For the purposes of this
entorhinal, I just did this online
learning thing. But as you can see,
that can lead to actually weirdly
suboptimal behavior where they don't
learn the true reward statistics very
well. And it depends on a bunch of
things too, like the learning rate. I
haven't explored this demo as much as I
would like, but there's a lot of
interesting kind of side effects. Like
here they're actually learning very
weird statistics about the bandit
landscape. They start kind of learning
it well, but then as their observations
keep going, they don't actually learn
very well here. They just avoid playing
because they have a bad early
experience. So this is an example of
like a bad bootstrap. And then they go
and just play the hint because they're
too scared of anything else, even though
their hidden states inference is perfect
because the hint perfectly tracks the
hidden state. So, yeah,
this is just kind of meant to be an
example of what you can do with
learning. But there's going
to be examples where learning actually
causes suboptimal behavior, but in an
interesting way. So here's an example
where they actually kind of are learning
the correct reward statistics. Things
are starting to converge to .8 for both
bandit arms, but it's very stochastic,
as you can see. And I also chose action
selection to be stochastic with
deterministic. I wonder what you would
get. Yeah,
you're there just arc maxing the
expected free energy or Marco mining.
So hint is always the most safest
option given their history of
observations.
If I can make one remark on that kind of
diversity of behaviors that we're
seeing, pymdp and
active inference are providing us a
space and and approach to composable
generative model construction that we
can then sift through and coevolve
with to find different strategies and
behaviors. Active inference lab or even
any specified generative model. It's not
an answer or a solution. For example,
to the explore explore dilemma. We see
this like empirically right now. Active
inference is not in general, resolving
Explore exploit. Any GM in general is
not resolving Explore exploit any
parameterization is not resolving
Explore exploit even for one
environment. It just is equivalent to
saying like, well, we have a linear
model of healthcare data, so we've
resolved the health care issue. And this
really shows the space that we build in
and what remains to be built is so
open yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
Because optimality is not really a
function of what the generative model is
or what the algorithm is. It's more
guaranteed to be optimal based on how
analogous the generative model and the
generative process are. So if the
generative model is a perfect model of
the generative process, then doing
Bayesian inference with respect to that
generative model, that is optimal for
everything. But how
you learn the generative model, that's
what we're seeing here. If you learn the
generative model in an online fashion,
it's not guaranteed to learn the right
generative model. In many cases, it
learns the wrong one. And this is
something that a lot of people in active
inference world have explore. For
instance, it's North Sajid, who's also a
student of Carl's, has explored a lot
the limitations and the boundaries of
parameter learning and things like
preference learning. Like what if you
were learning the C vector itself? How
can that be learned online in an
adaptive way? Yeah, and also Alec Chance
has that paper action Oriented models
where they're learning the B matrix.
And in that thing they're showing how
the agent learns kind of suboptimal
strategies depending on its exploration
of parameter space. But that also
actually is kind of one of the
benefits of active inference that paper
shows. Because it shows if you have an
agent that does have epistemic value,
the model it learns of the world is like
better than agents that don't have
epistemic value. But again, the models
are always action oriented. They're
always based on what parts of the full
state space is the agent driven to
sample.
Awesome. Yakup. Any closing comments and
then all the closing comment and then
Conor with the last word.
Yeah, well, thank you very much for
the great overview.
What particularly I
found particularly interesting was both
how you touched on how it could be
modified with the action perception
loop, could be modified with the other
modules, even though, as you mentioned,
there would be more opportunities to go
deeper in that, but also on the learning
the dershleigh parameters. And I
would be interested to see
how that also influences planning if
you would do kind of pseudo update of
your dirsh lay parameters when you're
calculating your expected free energy.
As in what would I'm calculating my
expected free energy whilst also taking
into account that my B would change on
each step and how that changes
like the optimality of the
temporal depths that we do planning
with. I think super interesting and
really looking forward to hopefully
another model stream.
Is it okay if I quickly respond? Yeah,
please. Yeah. That's a
very interesting point that you just
made about this fictive or imagined
update. Whereas this slide so that
term, that novelty term in theory that
does culture exactly what you're saying,
yakub, is that this thing says how would
my Dean sleep parameters update if I was
to take this policy pile? And then I use
that term to actually choose where to
explore next. So if I turn on the
parameter information gain term in the
agent class, they'll much more quickly
skip the hint and go directly to
sampling the bandits because they're
driven by novelty. I want to know what
the reward probabilities are, so I'm
going to go explore. However, what it
doesn't do and what I think you're
intimating with your comment is that if
I did like multi step planning two time
steps in the future, will I be able to
do my planning given how I think I
updated my parameters at the first time
step? So that's what the equivalent of
sophisticated inference, sophisticated
inference is saying, how would I plan
ant time step three given how I think my
beliefs would update up to time step
two? And that's done right now for
hidden states. But I haven't seen that
done for parameters. And I think there's
someone like a student of Ryan Smith's
is working on that now is like this
propagation of counterfactual beliefs
about how my parameter beliefs would
change in the future. And that's like a
really cutting edge, I think, active
inference. It's like not only novelty
but how would my perspective
sophistication about how your own
parameter beliefs will have evolved by
time point T and then using that to do
planning for time point T plus one,
that's like really sophisticated stuff.
I think getting just even bare Ronen
sophisticated inference with hidden
state counterfactual stuff in pinevp,
that would be a huge accomplishment too.
And then of course incorporating it to
be more with
the parameter sophistication as well.
And then another quick thing is I can
quickly show you an example of
one of those other let's
see.
Just while you're finding it, that last
discussion on sophisticated
planning. It's something that at the
semantic level we engage with every day.
What courses should I take this quarter
so that I can learn what I don't know
today so that next quarter I'll be able
to make a better plan for which classes
to take so that in three years when I
graduate DAG DA DA dot. But it's already
phrased at the semantic granularity
that these models are rapidly converging
towards and they're not converging
towards it by scaling is all you need.
They're converging towards it with a
factorized actually semantic approach
which is very exciting. Yeah, that's a
great analogy. If you were a naive
active inference agent without
sophistication you would never plan
with, like, a ten time step planning
horizon. You would never plan to take,
or let's say, a three semester plans
horizon. You never plan to take
multivariate calculus in your third
semester because you would not have
anticipated by the second semester I now
have enough linear algebra to take I
know that by the time I finish the
second semester, I will now know linear
algebra, so I'll be well suited to take
multivariable calculus. Whereas what we
as humans do is we do have that
parameter. Sophistication I can plan as
a freshman, as a first year to take in
my third or fourth semester some high
advanced physics because I know by that
time I will have the requisite
multivariable calculus or whatever. So
that's a really nice analogy that I
never I think that's a good example.
Welcome to active you. Yeah, exactly.
So here I just wanted to show
you yakub, here's an example of a
hierarchical hierarchical active
inference demo. I can share this too.
It's another collab notebook where we're
exactly doing we're composing two palm
DPS. So there's like a high level palm
DP and then there's a low level palm DP.
And for example, when you're doing a
step of updating the empirical priors at
the high level before you pass them down
to be empirical priors at the low level,
we use the control module, for example,
to do get expected states. We use the
high level beliefs, the high level B
matrix and then the high level chosen
action to propagate forward the next
postered beliefs at the high level. And
then those things themselves
parameterize a low level empirical prior
for this faster palm VP that's going on
at the low level. So this is an example
where you're composing like agent class
calls like this, but you're composing
them with functions that are built from
sub modules and adjacent modules of
PMDP. So that's an example of the thing
you were talking about. But yeah,
that's very brief. We can get into that
later on.
Ant a different stream or something like
that. Awesome.
Yes. Dot three, whenever the time
is right, I'll just give two closing
areas. Again, really appreciate
coming back on and sharing this
development in progress. Already it
feels more powerful and documented than
when we were in the dot one just a few
weeks or months ago. I think two areas
that are going to be really exciting to
discuss and see how they're implemented
and also the plurality of ways that
they're implemented. The first area is
structure learning on cognitive models
from the outside. So as an ethologist,
as a behavioral researcher, how do we do
structure learning on cognitive models
for systems that we actually know about
their cognitive architecture or not,
but also the view from the inside in
terms of structure learning and
metacognition. Like how should I change
the dimensionality of my B matrix or
should I turn on that flag to engage in
this kind of sophisticated inference?
So structure learning on cognitive
models, view from the outside, view from
the inside is one exciting area and the
second more experimental area is
statistical power analysis. Pre and
post hoc statistical power analysis
along the lines of the design matrix in
SPM so that you put 15 time
steps and zero 8.2 and punishment is
four. And then you could sweep across
parameters and learn about how well it
did. But if there was certain
interfaces, analytical or numerical
approaches to be like, yes,
with 25 time steps, we have this
much of an expectation of convergence,
or this differentiate in rewards should
be resolvable by an adaptive agent over
this long. And just understand,
how long should these experiments be?
Because there are such interesting
results with one shot learning and with
being able to generate someone's voice
from just 10 seconds of them talking,
or make a video of somebody as a deep
fake with just a still image. And so it
seems like it's possible to learn a lot
from a little. And if we can learn a lot
from a little and have a semantic
cognitive model, that would be quite
great. Absolutely.
Yeah. It's almost like hyper parameter
optimization on the landscape of active
inference models. Like, how do I choose
the parameters of an active inference
model? In a smart way? Yeah, there's
several methods for doing that that we
could definitely explore. Data
efficiency is the main thing, like you
said, making it so you don't have to
train it on a trillion images, like with
a deep neural network.
Perfect. End seven,
two. And whenever you want to join,
you and any colleagues are always
welcome to share the next spiral in Pi
MDP development. Awesome. Thank you so
much again for letting me come on and
listening. I hope it was helpful. Yeah,
and I'm glad that it's recorded. It's
really an amazing resource that you guys
are developing here. So thanks again.
Thank you. Till next time.